Tôi chức Mỹ ngày hôm nay mình một cho biết,
nghĩ phạm nổ xung kênh hai bình xí vệ bình của gia bị thông nặng gần nhà trắng,
là ra man nút la, lạc ăn quan, hay mình trên tôi,
công dân áp cả nistán tình là việc với lượng Mỹ trong gia đoạn trên trang.
Lạc ăn quan bị bán vi thương và bị không trình,
hay tại hiện trường sau khi mất ngờ tấn công,
hay bí xí đang tôn trà trước lỗi vào gà tạo diện gâm.
Chị cách nhà trắng vài giải phố, theo buồn như nổi nghiệm Mỹ,
lạc ăn quan vào Mỹ năm 2018,
theo chương trình, tại đình cửa của Operation Allies,
ra en chúng người Afghanistan hỗ trợ chuyển c истории in Washington,
người này đất cấp quý trẻ tiền nào và tháng tư,
nằm này vào không có tiền án.
App bị ý đăng điều tra đổ g!] trong đỏ không lợi trước,
khả nâng liên quan tại khủng bố.
Tổ nướng nâng tròm liên án tụt lộ xung là hạnh động độc áp vào thú hành
tình bố ra soát tòan bộ Hoa X Up cả Nistán nhập cạnh,
dối thời dann diễn kho ingredients chứng kiến chứ?
Can you say it,
Cái thực hiện chính quyền tảlevana chưa lại năm quyền năm 2019,
hôm nay, khoảng tà mời đến chiến miếng nghiệm nguyễn áp cả nistàn đã được lừa về Mỹ để giúp họ chẳng
Wico Bichato vụ tấn công tại thủ đô Washington cũng diễn ra trong lúc trình sách chình
khai bệnh bình cu ra tại nhiều thành phố công trăm tiếp tục ở tránh kái bố trường
trên tránh Mỹ P.H.C. cho biết tổng thống đã yêu cầu điều thêm năm 2014 từ thủ đô để tăng cường